tonight two area high schools are trying
to get to the bottom of violent threats
made against students the issues are
said to have stemmed from students who
are wearing trump clothing to school
victoria saha live near shadow high
school shadow ridge high school where
parents and students are fairly
concerned about it victoria
two different high schools but very
similar situations over here at shadow
ridge and over at arbor view i'm told
students have been coming in wearing
american flags and trump gear those
students tell me that this escalated
into threats being made against them
we are aware of rumors of threats to
both arbor view high school and shadow
ridge please know that we take all
threats very seriously that was the
voicemail parents woke up to friday
morning it's a sad day when you can't
drop the kids off at school without
worrying about terroristic threats from
other students arbor view high school
senior calvin wasden says he reported
the threats because he felt he and his
friends were the target he was told that
this kid was going to come shoot up to
school and not stop until he killed each
and every one of us wasden says he and
his friends have been coming to school
for several days wearing american flags
and other gear supporting the republican
party we have zero intention of
offending anybody
and i do not
hate anybody based on their political
views and there's no hate all love gates
says some students who didn't like this
went after his trump flag there's some
rips right here in the corners
and on the end of it during lunch
it was tied to my backpack correctly how
the principal asked us to tie it and a
student grabbed and ripped isabella
maggio at shadow ridge high school told
us half the students there did not show
up today a mother of a separate student
who asked to not be identified told us
her son was asked to remove a make
america great again hat several days ago
she says he took it off and pointed out
to administration that other students
were also wearing hats and now she says
her son is getting death threats some
parents said they agree with students
being able to portray their beliefs at
school as a military veteran i agree
with them they should be able to voice
their opinion and
act and
they have that right
for them to be denied that that's not
right either
i did reach out to the school district
to see if there has been any punishment
for those students who made those
threats i'm still waiting to hear back
reporting live from the northwest valley
victoria saha 8 news now